a minute silence was observed in the
German parliament in memory of the
victims of conflicts around the world
then chancellor makela give a speech
explaining our cabinet's decision to
send weapons to Kurdish fighters in
northern Iraq the semenza light
filamentous by the immense suffering of
so many people it cries out to us and
our own security interests are
threatened us bus is the current
situation weighs heavier on us than the
prospect of what might happen we have
the chance to help stop this inhumane
terrorist group now and to halt its
expansion Germany plans to send the
weapons this month the shipment will
include assault rifles and grenades and
anti-tank rockets equipment worth some
70 million euros the leader of the
Opposition says the move is a mistake
venya you got at fespa knew if a rock
has enough of anything its weapons and
I'll say this now so you'll know how it
happened it's not rare for the Peshmerga
fighters to hand over their weapons to
the Islamic state without a fight organ
is a 2-1 Islam rushed at the Green Party
also fears the weapons could fall into
the wrong hands they say the risks
associated with sending ordinance to the
region are incalculable so why she is
it's absolutely wrong to stand aside and
make deals without being able to foresee
and take responsibility for the
consequences of those deals Infante
weapon saponin lawmakers in Makka listen
ignored those concerns Parliament
overwhelmingly back the government's
decision